Let's go to the 4 0 8 area code caller from
4 0 8.
What's your name where you're calling from?
This is Logan from Saturday.
Hey, Logan, what's up?
I actually have another question on voter
turnout.
So with the, you know, all the Corona virus
restrictions in the social distance thing,
I'm hoping that stuff gets, you know, a lot
of it gets cleared up by November.
But I like the.
The after effects of it are going to last
longer, you know, people are going to go out
as much and you know, I'm just wondering.
I think there is going to be a lower voter
turnout in November.
But do you think that's good?
You know, historically, a lower verdict.
Voter turnout disproportionately hurts Democrats.
But do you think that's gonna be the case
or is it going to be more of an across the
board lower turnout?
You know, if you put a gun to my head and
say you've got a bet on it, my bet is that
the virus will impact voter turnout in November
in a way that helps Trump.
And the reason why I say that is Democrats
are taking the virus much more seriously than
Republicans.
Democrats are social distancing, much more
than Republicans.
So no matter what happens, my instinct is
there will be more Democrats who opt not to
go out in public in a large crowd at voting
locations than Republicans who will do that.
So I believe that the voter turnout dynamics
in November are going to be beneficial to
Donald Trump.
I want to be wrong and we need to work to
make that not be the case.
I think we should go to 100 percent absentee
ballot voting by mail.
But I think if we just have a normal everybody
shows up to vote on November 6th, I think
it helps Trump.
Right, right.
And, you know, it's obviously unprecedented,
so it's pretty hard to predict kind of shot
in the dark there.
Yeah.
All we can look at is on this during the social
distancing more seriously.
And that's what makes me think that.
OK.
Well, one other quick question on what I've
been thinking a little bit more about why
Bernie didn't do so well in the in the primary,
and I listen to some of your commentary saying
that, you know, the progressive platform isn't
necessarily as popular as Reddit and Twitter
would make you breathe.
And that's, you know, being young.
That's right.
I do spend a lot of my time.
So I was a little disappointed there.
But my question is, you know, moving forward,
maybe just that the next election, do you
think it would be beneficial for a progressive
candidate to kind of hone in, focus on on
one piece of the platform?
And naturally, that would be Medicare for
all?
Because I think that's the most popular and
can present a more, I guess, moderate stance
on some of the other progressive topics.
I don't know that I would say I don't know
that it's about being more moderate in some
areas and more progressive in other areas.
I think it's just about the framing and PR
around the campaign.
You can be progressive in five important areas.
But there is strategy, understanding where
you are running and your constituents to know
which one is more important.
So let me give you an example.
If you're in a very, very heavy union area
with manufacturing, for example, I don't fall
for this stuff.
Everybody loves their health plan.
But it is true that there are lots of unionized
workers who are satisfied with the health
care that they have because they've done collective
bargaining and they have something way better
than what lots of other people have in a place
like that.
You might want to focus more on maybe it's
minimum wage, maybe it's workers rights, maybe
it's education rather than maybe Medicare
for all, because you understand your constituency
where it is less of an issue for them to go
to Medicare for all because they like what
their union may have been able to negotiate
for them.
That doesn't mean you change your position
on Medicare for all.
It just means that maybe in your district
you campaign a little differently.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
He just kind of tailored the message to whoever
the audience is.
Right.
Exactly.
Doesn't mean you compromise on your values
or your positions, but the focus of your campaign
may be affected.
OK.
Last night I got for you today, I appreciate
you taking my call.
All right.
Thank you.
I appreciate you calling in.
Great to hear from you.